josep lago michel si roger paul journet
bonsoir alors on a quatre sujets on va y
aller rondement noël les plans pour noël
ont changé on a dit savez vous on vous
avais dit 4 c'est plus vraiment 4 on
écoute monsieur legault et on revient et
on a eu justement un avis peut-être plus
que l'apport de santé publique qui nous
est dit dans notre tête et un espace de
quatre jours mais faudrait pas que ça
soit plus que deux rassemblements alors
un espace de quatre jours mais pas plus
que deux rassemblements jose en réaction
parce que jude soir je pense ça qu'on
disait elle alors on s'est aperçu
peut-être qu'on est allé un peu trop
largement mais c'est un peu ce qu'on se
disait aussi à la semaine dernière et là
on retombe dans l'incohérence où les
messages qui sont change
la semaine dernière le premier ministre
disait pourtant bien le message est
simple et claire o'petit quelques jours
plus tard échanges déjà moi j'ai même
des amis qui m'ont téléphoné cet après
midi ballon comprend plus rien qu est ce
qu on a droit de faire de pas faire
pendant ce temps à la santé canada eux
ils sont allés ils ont plus les colts
lattes acteurs cesser le travail c'est à
dire rester chez vous dans la mesure du
possible donc on réduit les contacts au
maximum j'espère qu'au cours des
prochains jours le gouvernement au
québec requalifier la laisser dans leur
esprit c'est clair est-ce que ça
pourrait être changée là ils disent
michele si ces deux jours plus tôt 4 on
est on a été trop permissif on
s'aperçoit que ça c'est potentiellement
c'est dangereux santé canada jozi le
souligner à dire essais dont un dans
votre bulle familiale l'on est ce qu on
a été trop généreux jeudi où l'on
entretient la couverte qu'est-ce que
j'en avais dit de toute façon ça dépend
de la situation sanitaire c'était pas le
temps de faire ces annonces le sont
peut-être pour le calendrier scolaire
parce qu'il sort chez les jeunes la
tarder et pour le reste on sait pas
c'est quoi
c'est dans un mois on sait pour quelle
soit la situation sanitaire à ce que se
soit apaisée qu'à ce moment alors
peut-être plus que deux jours ou si ce
sera pire encore et où on
on va prendre les conseils du docteur 40
euros on va rester chacun chez nous on
ne le sait pas c'est pas possible de
savoir à ce moment aussi a pas de boule
de cristal pour personne alors attendons
encore quelques pour quelques jours ou
quelques semaines
oui mais y avait une pression énorme
pour les gens veulent savoir les gens
oui vous avez raison ça c'est ça ça
reste clair ça peut changer pas de
journée mais oui il y avait ainsi dans
l' annonce du gouvernement a le goût
puis on dirait que tout le monde l'a
oublié peut-être parce qu'il ne voulait
pas l'entendre mais un énorme si qui
était de savoir tout ce qui est tout ce
qu on veut le permettre pour noël si si
et seulement si la situation
épidémiologique qui le permet maintenant
pour ce qu'il annonce du 4 jours c'est
nécessaire la préciser parce qu'y en a
qu'il avait l'intention on dirait de
partir sur un espèce de zapoï le une
brosse ininterrompue de 96 heures alors
là on a dit écoutez ces quatre jours de
possibilités mais on vient là nuance
depuis le début qui est celle entre
d'une part ce qui est permis et ce qui
est recommandé
et ce qui est recommandé c'est de
minimiser volet fait pendant les quatre
jours voire de ne pas en faire mais
quand même la permission pendant quatre
jours c'est nécessaire parce que le
québec c'est les familles souvent
recomposée il y en a qui ont plusieurs
feuilles de noël ou pour qui c'est
compliqué de gérer tout ça donc quatre
jours c'était nécessaire d'avoir une
assez longue période
aussi pour les travailleurs de la santé
qui s'ils travaillent le 24 mai ils
veulent pouvoir et aussi savoir avec
leurs proches mais donc tout ça va être
revue et 10 du quatre jours ça ça me
semble une bonne idée
très bien alors le vaccin maintenant le
vaccin monsieur trudeau on va l'écouter
a dit vous allez entendre parler des
gens qui se font vacciner aux états unis
en allemagne en grande-bretagne nous il
faudra attendre plus longtemps voici
pourquoi on n'a pas de capacité de
production de masse de vaccins au canada
on en avait il ya plusieurs décennies
mais depuis ces années là on n'a plus
notre capacité domestique d'autres pays
qui en ont comme à les états unis là
en bretagne l'allemagne et d'autres
évidemment vont prioriser l'accès à
leurs vaccins pour leurs citoyens
d'abord voilà on n'a pas les capacités
de production donc michel c'est ogier il
faudra attendre même si on en a commandé
des millions des millions de doses
ils vont évidemment servir dans les
premiers jours les premiers oui c'est
évident mais en même temps comment ça se
fait que c'est aujourd'hui qu'on apprend
la première chose qui va frapper quand
j'entends ça de la part de monsieur
trudeau ca bon vous vous le saviez
depuis l'automne vous auriez pu dire
déjà depuis un bout de temps
vous savez ça va probablement prendre un
mois avec les américains ou les
allemands ou les français puisque avancé
à se faire vacciner que nous on est une
ode aux c'était juste de la transparence
de base ça pas été fait plus aujourd'hui
on a l'impression que le boulot on le
savait depuis longtemps mais voulait
juste pas le dire aux citoyens
ça c'est jean d'âcre au québec qui est
assez fatigant parce que ces quads le
reste qui nous disent pas pu on est dans
un monde de complotiste épique théorie
du complot puis de vidéos sur youtube
ça aurait été mieux de 0 vous auriez
aimé dans ce cas là contrairement à
l'autre cas plus de précisions plutôt
oui c'était très facile de le donner
aucun pas de journée imaginez si nous on
regarde à la télévision puis on voit
qu'il ya des gens en europe qui sont en
train de se faire vacciner alors on est
rendu à la fin de l'hiver quand on est
royalement écoeuré qui a encore de la
neige d'or pic à cause de la pandémie on
doit continuer à limiter nos
déplacements la grogne va être grande
et puis il me semble que c'est dans
l'intérêt de tout le monde y compris de
celui du gouvernement de baisser les
attentes en ce sens d'autant plus que
peut-être on va avoir une situation de
campagne électorale je peux me lancer
dans les scénarios est bon le printemps
prochain
c'est pas c'est pas impossible avec
dernière chose à ajouter
comme rappelé que la stratégie du
gouvernement fédéral c'est de pas mettre
tous ses oeufs dans le même panier
en concluant des contrats avec
différentes compagnies pour avoir
commencé à rentrer dans l'équation le
fait qu'on est de diversifier nos
ressources potentielles pour les achats
de vaccins
parce que là dessus il veut ils se
veulent rassurants depuis des semaines
disons-le a acheté près de 100 millions
de doses
on en à s'épiler compagne et qu'on a
choisi c'est celle qui arrive avec de
bons résultats à la fin de la course la
jauge et oui c'est ça la nuance est à
que le gouvernement fédéral réservé des
doses et c'est sûr que je pense pas que
les canadiens les québécois vont avoir
énormément de patience lors d'un en
ouvre à cnn par voyant des américaines
en matinée le savoir toit est agréable
du tout ça peu coûteux politiquement
aussi donc oui on comprend que il ya
peut-être une priorité parce qu'on n'a
pas une capacité de production ici mais
je pense que ça va être aussi de la
responsabilité du gouvernement fédéral
d'exercer des pressions sur ces
compagnies pharmaceutiques là qui ont
extrêmement bien travaillé mais là on
est face à une pandémie mondiale et nous
sommes tous interdépendants un moment
donné les frontières vont ouvrir un bon
déjà on voit déjà arriver des états unis
moi je vois des plaques
d'immatriculation de la californie dans
mon coin je sais pas d'où elles viennent
pas et où il est
et là on le monde entier et terreur
dépendants en réalité c'est la planète
qu'il faut vacciner
la chaîne gouvernement de préciser ces
choses mais l'or comme le 10ème chelsea
d'apprentis aujourd'hui c'est c'est cesc
autant oui c'est le quota comme si on
n'est pas dans les complots mais comme
si j'avais une mauvaise nouvelle de ces
grandes entreprises là ottawa paul en
dix ans va écouter la savoir tête est un
peu plus long que prévu vos vacances et
vos avions 2
le don roose là c'est des fois c'est
difficile d'essayer de comprendre ce qui
se passe dans la tête du gouvernement
fédéral par rapport à la communication
de leur message en allemand je veux pas
spéculer peut-être aussi qu'ils ont
juste oublié d'y penser mais en même
temps plus on si on avait planifié
vraiment à l'avancé la gestion de la
distribution des vaccins
si on le fait c'est quelque chose qu'on
avait dû voir arriver dès le début mais
des fois et des gouvernements qui ont
des informations embarrassantes puis il
décide pas de les données de les
dévoiler de leur propre initiative qui
attendent qu'on pose la bonne question
pour donner la réponse
très bien alors on va voir puis le
québec je le souligne en passant parce
que hier on a beaucoup parlé au panel
dit monsieur dubé dione on n'a pas
besoin de général à la retraite nous on
ne se soucie ministre qui va s'occuper
de tout ça et on verra alors là
évidemment on verra ça dans les faits si
c'est bien organisé
ça doit l'être en fait personne n'a le
droit à l'erreur dans ce domaine là pour
que les doses arrive vraiment chez les
gens la loi
je veux parler du français parce que je
me suis jallet barrette
on peut plus ils atteindront peut plus
d'attendre comme le cheval qui veut
sortir de l' est un pilote autre point
de presse aujourd'hui pour nous dire ça
s'en vient
josée legault c'est simplement pour dire
je vous ai pas oublié votre journal a
fait cette série pour montrer que dans
les commerces à montréal ont de la
difficulté à se faire accueillir en
français il vous dira ça s'en vient mais
ce sera pas avant janvier finalement un
bon fait pendant la session
parlementaire donc la prochaine ça peut
être pensez pas que quelque part
non c'est que là bas il ya eu il ya eu
deux problèmes si j'allais voir être
aujourd'hui il ya eu justement là c'est
le fait qu'il sort à nouveau puis ses
propres ici non ce qu'il va faire et
quand est ce qu'ils voient leur père
et puis aussi toute la question des cga
fans donc étendre la loi 101 au cégep
oui ou non grande question existentielle
moi j'ai jamais cru que gouvernement le
ferait les gouvernements précédents ne
l'ont pas fait non plus mais cet après
midi monsieur j'allais m'arrêter dit je
suis en réflexion et moins factice
je crois que j'ai vu son nez allongé
quand il est ce vous voulez vous me
devancé jean ferrat jallet paraître qui
dit qu'on est à ce qui m'avait dit la
même chose en entrevue à trois semaines
on est en réflexion c'est possible qu'on
a jusque là mais je les entends le
premier ministre ferme et très
clairement au salon bleu on écoute ce
que les cégeps pouvons être assujetti à
la loi 101
je suis toujours un pot finement du plan
d'action mais un élément qui est
fondamentale et qui se retrouvera dans
mon plan d'action c'est le fait que la
langue normale habituel des études
devraient demeurer le français alors je
suis toujours en réflexion présentement
le quand même apporter une précision on
va regarder la situation des cg pour
voir comment on peut mieux s'assurer que
les gens étudient en français mais y est
pas question d'étendre la loi 101 au
cégep comme le propose peut-être parti
québécois ça dépend de quel chef qui on
part alors je voulais terminer jose est
rapidement passé les deux ont donc à
monsieur legault a fermé la boîte
oui mais l'erreur du ministre ça a été
de laisser en femme qu'elle est est
ouverte bon je sais pas si c'était pour
conforter certaines personnes mais
monsieur le goût ne le fera pas les
autres premiers ministres ne l'ont pas
fait et pour une raison très très très
simple c'est que à moins qu'on ait des
nouvelles mesures qui m'échappe là mais
il ya une grande partie francophone qui
eux mêmes sont opposés à ceux qui
veulent garder ce droit d'envoyer leurs
enfants étudiants nac estivale d'aller à
dos le temps d'aller ailleurs pour moi
cas là est d'ailleurs le gouvernement va
donner beaucoup d'argent au collège
dawson aussi donc je n'ai jamais jamais
jamais vu venir et je n'hésite à dire
jamais passé comme sous le bois la terre
et j'ai pas compris non plus pourquoi le
ministre a laissé entendre qu'il est
avec wayne michel est ce qu'il ya un
vrai débat a coulé sous passé où c'est
réglé cette question là monsieur janin
barrette plaide à haute voix de toute
évidence monsieur j'allais barrette
voudrait aller plus loin que son premier
ministre et probablement pas seulement
sur la question des cégeps moi j'ai hâte
de voir si par exemple on va sortir aux
entreprises qui ont moins de 50 employés
noah sahara puis à toutes les exigences
que ça veut dire monsieur legault qui
vient du milieu des affaires
je pense sûr que c'est ça qui m sur
beaucoup et à la fin il faudra voir si
tout ce qu'on va en faire pour renforcer
la loi 101 vont vraiment avoir un effet
sur le terrain
je vous donne un exemple tout le monde a
l'air de vouloir que les entreprises de
juridiction fédérale soit ton sous
l'égide de la loi 101 tant mieux mais
c'est 135 la vaillance à ses portes
taxes et cedar des domaines les banques
les télécommunications où il ya
tellement de concurrence qu'on espère
les clients là
à leur répondre que la mauvaise langue
c'est pas il n'ya pas pire pas vraiment
plein dans ces domaines alors qu'est ce
qu'on va changer réalité sur le terrain
si on fait ça mais j'ai hâte de voir
quel est le plan legault qui le plonge
les barrettes jeu projection des fois on
avait l'impression aujourd'hui messieurs
jolie barrette parler comme s'il était
le premier ministre puis s'est fait
rappeler qu'ils ne l'étaient pas après
mais bon à sa décharge il voulait il
voulait montrer qu'il était ferme dans
ses intentions de renforcer le français
et qu'aucune mesure n'était écartée
d'emblée essence leur qui prend porte
c'est pas la question il disait je
l'exclus pas j'y pense mais dans les
faits même le parti québécois après des
débats houleux alain terne redit qu'il
n'irait pas là si le parti québécois
veut pas aller jusque là on sait déjà
que la coalition avenir québec ne voudra
pas puis toute façon ce débat s'est déjà
déroulée en 2013 quand monsieur legault
était là comme chef de l'opposition pour
la cac
puis il avait refusé la réforme le
renforcement de la loi sans de madame
marois donc on sait déjà un peu où il
loge mais ça ça se résume assez
simplement aujourd'hui un ministre ça
rio rien à annoncer la saison que les
médias essayent de trouver une nouvelle
famille peuvent sait ce qu'est ce que ça
ne fait pas dernier tour de table très
rapide ça ne fait pas que monter les
attentes parce que là on s'arrête en
janvier vous allez voir tout à fait
extraordinaire jose mais je pense que
c'est pour ça que monsieur leubou est
sorti après aussi justement pour pour
baisser les armes
mais vous savez monsieur legault occupe
déjà 99% du terrain politique du
nationaliste au québec alors avec ça il
va peut-être aller chercher le dernier 1
pour ça et il faut obliger d'en faire
beaucoup pour aller chercher celle ci
montréal doit quand on va déposer cette
chose-là jose est quelque chose
d'important à présent après j'ai un
sport en janvier qu'on a dit c'est ici
la fin de la session
c'est la fin de la session c'est un
autre joueur alors puis après ça
l'adoption reviendra à l'automne
paul dernier mot à vous en septembre
monsieur legault avait déjà dit qu'il
voulait probablement que ce soit déposée
au début de l'hiver donc on imagine que
l'espoir du gouvernement quartier c'est
que ce soit déposée à l'hiver et que ce
soit adopté avant
le début de la pré campagne électorale
provinciale et peut-être même la
campagne municipale
j'ai pas le temps pour les chevreuils de
longueuil on apparaît une autre fois
promis à tout à l'heure